imiter la nature hâter son oeuvre ce
vieil adage bien connu des forestiers
semble plus que jamais d'actualité
selon les dernières estimations de l'onu
et malgré les nouveaux engagements pris
lors de la cop 26 le monde se dirige
vers une augmentation de la température
moyenne de la terre de 2,7 degrés
ces variations affecte d'ores et déjà
les conditions de vie de la forêt qui
couvre 31 % de notre territoire
son cycle naturel est perturbée par le
bouleversement des saisons les incendies
se multiplient les attaques parasitaires
soient plus fréquentes
aujourd'hui source de revenus
économiques et pourvoyeuse d'emplois par
le biais de la production de bois la
forêt française parce qu'elles captent
15% des émissions de co2 annuelle du
pays semble être la solution rêvée pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
mais la filière forêt bois avec un
déficit commercial cumulé de 7 milliards
d'euros représente le deuxième poste de
dépense du pays juste après les
hydrocarbures
de plus la société civile se dresse
désormais contre les coupes rases et nos
cultures ces pratiques jugées néfastes
pour l'environnement consistant
l'abattage de la totalité des arbres et
la culture d'une essence unique sur une
même parcelle
mais alors comment répondre aujourd'hui
aux besoins de la france en matière de
captation de co2 tout en redressant une
filière déficitaire et en veillant à la
préservation des écosystèmes
je suis journaliste et je travaille sur
des sujets liés à l'écologie et à
l'économie face à la multiplication des
problèmes liés à la hausse des
températures
je me suis intéressé au fonctionnement
de l'exploitation forestière en france
[Musique]
rapidement débordé par la masse
d'informations
j'ai fait appel à mon confrère grégoire
spécialiste des questions
environnementales
ensemble nous avons décidé d'enquêter
sur ces enjeux cruciaux
au fil des déplacements et des
rencontres sur le terrain nous avons
découvert une filière secoué par une
crise idéologique sur fond de changement
climatique
comment la france prépare aujourd'hui sa
foire et ses forêts à un avenir
incertain
en france 90% des principales essences
d'arbres possède par ravageur qui se
développe à cause du réchauffement
climatique comme par exemple la chenille
processionnaire du pin ou du chêne dans
la région nord-est c'est le scolyte qui
ravagent des monocultures entière
d'épicéa
grégoire se rend dans les ardennes pour
constater l'ampleur des dégâts
sur place il rencontre raphaël qui faire
agents de l'eau nf l'organisme d'état
chargé de la gestion des forêts
publiques
ces dernières nous présente un quart de
la surface totale forestière française
ici la totalité les arbres sombres on
est sur une forêt d'épicéas qui ont été
attaqués par un insecte le scolyte je
suis en poste depuis 2015 est clairement
le problème les premières grosses
attaques de scolytes qu'on a eu on lui
en 2010 est à peu près ça n'a pas arrêté
ça n'a fait qu'augmenter depuis et
comment il explique principalement par
le réchauffement climatique une
amélioration de leurs conditions de vie
ce sont des insectes qui faisait parfois
un cycle de reproduction par an
aujourd'hui on peut avoir trois quatre
cycles de reproduction donc la
population augmente en a plus d'insectes
et comme ces insectes se nourrissent de
l'arbre ils vont forcément avoir besoin
de manger plus d'arbres donc de détruire
et de tuer plus d'un
on est face à un épicé scolytés
et on peut très bien voir si je retire
cette écorce
on peut très bien voir toutes les
galeries donc en fait les scolytes vont
percer des petits trous qu'on voit ici
et ils vont rentrer entre les corses et
le bois et ils vont creuser des galeries
qu'on distingue la d'accord puis on va
les voir aussi
sur l'arbre qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
ça ce qui est là donc un arbre mort le
principal moyen de lutte contre ces
insectes c'est au moment où les insectes
sont dans l'arbre de couper l'arbre et
de l'évacuer de la forêt plus vite
possible
[Musique]
pour comprendre les raisons de ce
désastre j'ai souhaité rencontrer max
bruch hammachi
ingénieur et professeur à agroparistech
spécialiste économique et écologique de
la forêt française
[Musique]
l'épicière en plein ça a été une erreur
on l'a introduit pas mal à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale parce qu'on
voulait produire plus de pâte à papier
et
et en gros on a introduit une essence
qui est normalement on pousse en
altitude on l'a ramené en plaine en
plaine il fait beaucoup plus chaud donc
elle pousse pendant plus longtemps on a
des rendements en volume qui sont
énormes l'inconvénient c'est que il est
vachement plus sensibles au fait qu'il
ya des étés secs à l'époque où ça a été
fait on n'avait pas connaissance de ça
on était trop sensible à la production
matières l'indicateur s'était de vous
faire les deux là pourraient produisent
des mètres cubes sans prendre en compte
les risques de cette production on a
planté des surfaces qui nous pose
problème à l'heure actuelle
[Musique]
et où quelque chose qui a été fait à une
époque moi je ne jette pas la pierre aux
prédécesseurs par contre à la charge à
nous de tirer les leçons de cette erreur
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire
autrement que d'avoir un constat d'échec
on en a combien d'hectares scolytés est
coupée dans cette forêt domaniale bah là
on va on va être qu'on va atteindre les
150 170 hectares d'un seul tenant camper
à blanc ça représente un hectare c'est
un terrain de football un donc là on est
à plus de 150 terrains de football 1 ça
maintenant
aujourd'hui il ya une partie de la
filière qui souhaitent utiliser cette
opportunité puisque on rase les forêts
qu'on doit les reconstruire pour
reconstruire des forêts de production
pour industrialiser le milieu naturel
forestier
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on a
des soucis sanitaires sur toutes nos
essences principal donc on est amené à
déboiser énormément de surface sous
couvert de crise sanitaire et du coup la
forêt française arrive à un carrefour il
ya une décision à prendre il ya un choix
une orientation en termes de politique
forestière à faire est-ce que l'on
choisit de ne pas faire confiance à la
nature et de dire l'être humain va
intervenir parce que la nature va être
mis en échec par le changement
climatique
ou est ce qu'on choisit de se dire
faisons confiance à la nature elle va
trouver les moyens la nature de réagir
peut-être qu'on ne les connais pas
encore tout de suite mais du coup le
métier de forestier s'intégrera
parfaitement dans une mission
d'observation d'études d'inventaire de
diagnostic pour comprendre ces
phénomènes naturels qui vont se mettre
en place et chercher le plus possible à
les imiter il ya une confrontation sur
ces deux visions
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser trois quarts de la forêt
française appartient à des propriétaires
privés
ceux qui veulent tirer profit de leurs
parcelles confient leur exploitation à
des coopératives et des gestionnaires
ils planifient la récolte du bois et
valorise la matière première
pour les rencontrer grégoire se rend à
la foire forexpo à mimizan dans les
landes
il s'agit d'un événement incontournable
permettant de mettre en relation les
propriétaires privés et des entreprises
d'exploitation forestière
[Musique]
rien sont proposés sur les différentes
la rue
[Musique]
puis à césar
et dames et messieurs bienvenue à cette
utopie celle de fausto
sa jambe est nanti toujours
sur 30 jours je vous dis tu t'attaches
d'alliance ordina beaucoup
des bases et donc si vous voyez ce
documentaire sur la
trois expos on arrive par son adjoint
merci à vous
en juillet
bonjour monsieur vie est bon bonjour
vous représentez alliance forêt bois la
plus importante coopérative forestière
de france vous présentez combien
d'adhérents donc si on regroupe quarante
mille adhérents qui sont propriétaires
effectivement des pyrénées jusqu'à la
scène en fait c'est tout type
d'adhérents vous avez des propriétaires
qui habitent à côté leur forêt des
propriétaires qui habitent très loin des
petites surfaces des plus grandes
surfaces donc nous on est chargé de
répondre à leurs attentes et à leurs
demandes voilà donc on va leur dire
écoutez on va planter plus tôt telle
espèce parce que parce que vu
l'évolution va effectivement avant il y
avait du être mais dû être il va
disparaître il sera plus adapté et donc
on va vous proposer d'autres solutions
nous on va leur proposer des choses
techniques mais il faut bien comprendre
que au bout du bout celui qui en a à la
fois la responsabilité et de gardiennage
déjà géré de la forêt c'est le
propriétaire frauciel
les coopératives ont été créés suite à
une demande de la fédération des
propriétaires forestiers pour faire un
peu ce qui se passait dans le monde
agricole vous savez qu'en forêt privée
il ya à peu près 3 millions 5,2
propriété avait beaucoup de toutes
petites propriétés il ya deux millions
quatre cd propriété qui ont moins de 1
ha donc on dit souvent que la forêt
française est très morcelé c'est vrai et
en même temps vous avez aussi en forêt
privée des gros propriétaires
donc il y avait ce besoin à la fois
que bon il y avait des gens qui déjà
aidé les gros propriétaires mais il y
avait aussi ce besoin d' essayer
d'animer la petite propriété le petit
souci à l'heure actuelle c'est que les
coopératives est long il me semble à mon
avis déjà un peu oublié cet objectif
puisque elles se sont regroupées elles
sont devenues de plus en plus grosse et
et l'animation de la petite propriété
était un petit peu mise de côté quoi
elles ont une logique industrielle
souvent et c'est plus mouvement leur
priorité
le problème de la forêt française c'est
pas sa surexploitation cessa
sous-exploitation la forêt française
croît à peu près de 90 millions de
mètres cubes par an on en récolte à
peine 60 donc il ya 30 millions de
mètres cubes de plus par an dans les
forêts françaises il n'y a jamais eu
autant de bois sur pied depuis 2 3 4 5 6
5 c'est qu'en font les français qui
présente du matériel en circulation
derrière vous vous avez un parc de
matériels et en commençant et les clés
adapté aux travaux publics pour des
raisons environnementales c'est moins
d'émissions c'est moins de 2 pu mais
c'est moi également
solution sur nord
[Musique]
l'enjeu majeur qui est devant nous c'est
le changement climatique dirk la forêt
française n'a jamais autant besoin de
l'homme que dans les 50 prochaines
années la forêt française ne pourrait
pas réagir aux changements climatiques
qui va beaucoup trop vite pour que elle
s'adapte naturellement il va falloir
qu'on intervienne pour l'aider à
s'adapter à ce climat qu'on nous annonce
de demain on est dans l'action donc et
dans l'action la réflexion et dans les
investissements en investi dans nos
pépinières on investit dans verte dans
des vergers à grain qui ont fourni les
arbres qui ont été adaptées au
changement climatique on est dans
l'action on n'est pas dans la
contemplation
maintenant voilà on au tournant qui ont
donc
intérêt un bien propre guerre régulier
et le planteur qu'au bruit et là bas est
équipé d'un harnais qui lui permet de
porter les blancs sont donc dans un port
thouars spécifiques et c'est lesquels il
a un plan parfait et la mise en place se
faire dès qu'un tube plongeur cette
notion d'urgence de risques par exemple
par rapport au changement climatique il
faut relativiser par rapport à ça il ya
souvent un argument qui est de dire il
faut tout changer parce que si on s'y
prend pas maintenant demain ça sera trop
tard cette inquiétude de ne pas servir
de prétexte à une augmentation de
l'artificialisation des forêts vous
entendez par là une vision simpliste
tout enlever repartir à zéro en pensant
que ce sera mieux plus tard ouais trouvé
trouvé une naissance c'est ça où est
cette fameuse essence pire acte qui sera
adapté au climat futur tout en étant
adaptés à tous les climats qu'il faut
intervenir avant d'arriver au climat le
futur qui va être bien adapté
l'introduction de l'écosystème qui va
pas trop perturber l'écosystème qui
cette fameuse essence miracle tout le
monde cherche qui tirent pas de sens
quoi
aura lieu à 14 heures on a commencé à 10
heures je pense que ça n'est pas verni
mais
sinon ces travaux à 14 heures pour la
deuxième mort et débardage
oui il ya une logique aussi où le sol
est décaissé et à chaque fois on
recommence à zéro c'est vraiment logique
d'une plantation pas même si eux
appellent ça une forêt oui en fait on
est clairement dans la logique agricole
chaque année on a eu 25 dossiers de
candidature pour mettre 3 puis le
premier trophée c'est le trophée dans un
forestier 2021 et attribuées aux
porteurs bilan actif frame monsieur
marco matiga alors il ya aussi donc le
trophée et un petit diplôme mais moi ce
que je pourrais voir votre attention à
l'instant je m'appelle bruno dit et
travaille pour l'association canopée
pour est vivante on est venu parce que
nous aussi on aura trop faire renaître
cette fois-ci relais directement dans la
catégorie description du vivant puisque
c'est le trophée du plus grand
destructeur de biodiversité que vous
avez la donne à nous on a choisi de le
remettre à la coopérative alliance forêt
bois bravo à l'honneur
vous ne pouvez pas raconter des choses
fausses que ça la biodiversité si vous
n'avez qu'à aller la chercher vous la
trouverez non nationaux souligné gérard
des chicanes nom du feuillu partout
faits pareils enterrant placé par les
monocultures vous voyez beaucoup de
temps
il faudrait qu'on puisse vous montrer à
quoi ressemble la diversité dans la
forêt de gaza
[Musique]
une pétition pour interdire les koopas
sur notre site vous invite à signer ce
lait vendu un succès ici
mais vous de ce qui vous donne pas le
droit de parler comme ça
tous les jours nous on nous signale des
coupes rases dans les feuillus
et ses messages de sécurité
d'un doute est là bas nous vous invitons
à la voir avec les caméras étaient
braquées sur des bancs récemment je suis
pas venu en soit je suis syndicat
d'élevage et au rejet par les alliances
après six rencontres des vous voulez
surtout par cette fois ci apprend forêt
avec toutes les caméras de
la monoculture de la saison avec des
caméras j'ai pas la coupe rase honteuse
ces dernières années des voix s'élèvent
contre les pratiques des grands acteurs
de la filière considéré comme trop
industrielle est nocive pour
l'environnement la coupe rase et
particulièrement ciblé
ya beaucoup de débats aujourd'hui dans
la société autour d'une pratique c'est
ce qu'on appelle la coupe rase ou la
coupe à blanc à quoi ça sert une coupe
rase quand on fait de la forêt de
production
quel est l'intérêt cette pratique fondée
la première premier intérêt c'est que on
va couper l'ensemble des arts parce que
c'est un peuplement qui est homogène et
tous les arbres vont avoir le même âge
ils arrivent à maturité en même temps
comme il arrive à maturité en même temps
on les récolte puisque la cupra c'est
bien un récolte en même temps mais ça
varie aussi sûrement les essences sur le
pin maritime par exemple quelles
questions aux presque on fait une coupe
rase parce que c'est une essence de
lumière et mettre en place des jeunes
peuplements à l'ombre des peuplements
plus anciens et bien il ne pourrait pas
pousser donc ils ont besoin de cette
lumière pour quartz et donc on passe par
les coupes rases si on ne récolte pas
par blocs ici des landes de gascogne on
a une rupture des produits issus du pin
maritime on peut citer les emballages et
médicaments tout ce qui est de cartons
etc et donc deux possibilités soit on
réduit tous notre consommation on arrête
les commandes sur internet on arrête les
envois et ses cartons autres on les
diminue amplement ou soi et bien
on accepte ce mode de gestion en disant
que finalement la coupe rase
c'est ponctuel et après on met en place
des nouveaux peuplement qui eux
bénéficient d'une sylviculture moderne
voire de l'amélioration génétique
puisque les nouveaux plans qui sont mis
en place après la cupra sont souvent des
plans qui sont améliorées génétiquement
j'ai pas dis ogm j'ai bien dit améliorer
génétiquement sert croisement de parents
qui ont un certain nombre de
caractéristiques un peu la sélection
comment faire mieux agricole par exemple
est exactement
[Musique]
oh
cette approche intensive de la gestion
forestière semble avoir suscité la
colère d'une partie de la population
les citoyens s'emparent du sujet de la
forêt et des alternatives sylvicoles
fleurissent partout en france
parmi celles ci le groupement forestier
écologique à venir forêts gérées par
suzanne braun ingénieur des eaux et
forêts elle pratique et défend la
sylviculture continue appelé aussi futée
irrégulière
dans ces parcelles pas de coupes rases
pour replanter des arbres améliorer
génétiquement
elle effectue des éclaircies ponctuelles
pour permettre aux arbres prometteur de
recevoir la lumière nécessaire à leur
développement
suzanne organise régulièrement des
visites dans ces parcelles pour faire
découvrir son approche
grégoire part à sa rencontre en corrèze
sur place il fait la connaissance de
stéphane erard le président d'une jeune
association citoyenne dans le puy de
dôme qui est venu s'inspirer du travail
de suzanne du coup c'est un peu les deux
antithèses parce que le être
comme elle ils souhaitent acquérir des
parcelles forestières promouvoir et
appliquer des pratiques sylvicoles
proche de la nature moi je rêve de
racheter ces parcelles j'ai déjà tout
mesurer les surfaces etc parce que c'est
us est simple original quand même de la
est très petit mais de quoi tu vois
[Musique]
il ya une chaîne qui déchaîne
il ya du chêne
natale épicé accueil sympa
mais à douglas aussi oui je dis bêtise
ça c'est d'oublier ça ces épisodes wii
s'est pas laissé passé pas toujours non
il faut faire attention le très clair ça
c'est un épicéa mais qui déjà un peu
âgées
petits champignons
mais le sage parce que
nous quand on a acheter on se disait bon
on enrichit un peu on appris des
sauvageons qui sauvent agences et des
plantes sauvages de nos régénération
naturelle qu'on a trouvé à côté donc on
a déplacé des êtres on a déplacé des
épicéas on a déterré des sapin pectiné
on a fait nos tests enrichissement ça a
plus ou moins marché et après on a
laissé tomber parce que l'entretien
c'est quand même du temps et de l'argent
et on voit au bout de sept ans qui lie à
la nature qui a mieux fait mon job on va
dire parce que les êtres autour c'est
des arbres semenciers qui ans mais qui
ont recolonisé par milliers moi si je
devrais mettre l'argent pour planter
tout ça ça me coûterait trop d'argent
donc là c'est la nature qui a fait le
travail à ma place moi j'ai qu'à
attendre et intervenir au bon moment
pour faire du sélectif et favoriser les
plus belles tish ça c'est donc tu gardes
une envie de dans la gestion il ya quand
même un intérêt économique qui reste
c'est à dire on garde des belle tige
pour pouvoir potentiellement les
valoriser dans 50 60 cents ans notre
affaire où notre projet c'est quand même
avec un objectif d économies qui
derrière il faut que ça soit durable
avec le fonctionnement de la nature et
c'est là au moins chez voie en impasse
dans le traitement classique de la
filière où ça aboutit en coupes rases
parce que ça demande trop d'apport
d'énergie par l'homme tandis que dans un
système forestier normal on n'a pas cet
effort à faire c'est ça l'intérêt de
jouer avec ce qu'on voit avec ce qui
marche et pas le détruire pour à mettre
encore plus d'efforts et plus plus de
moyens financiers pour peut-être échoué
au bout de 20 ans moi je prendrait pas
ce risque fut-il régulière ça existe
depuis les siècles en suisse en
allemagne donc j ai pas on va inventer
la roue j'ai juste
j'applique ce qui me semble le bon sens
la serriculture a couvert continue son
principe une approche par an il ya
différents types de civils culture on
peut les regrouper en deux gros paquets
celles qui vivent une approche par arbre
et celles qui ont une approche par
surface quand vous avez une approche par
arbre vous décidez imparable dont vous
êtes beaucoup plus dans la variabilité
de ce qui caractérise un écosystème
c'est la variabilité des essences des
qualités des dimensions des capacités de
réaction
faut pas oublier que souvent un faible
pourcentage de volume assure l'essentiel
de la récolte financière d'une propriété
il suffit de bien choisir quel arbre
cela on va leur donner une fonction
financière importante et puis à côté les
autres ont des tas d'autres fonctions
les mélanges d'essence est bon pour la
régénération de votre naissance il ya
des tas de choses qui se passent en
forêt que l'on pourrait utiliser
et quand on fait ça on n'a pas besoin
que enfin tous les arbres jouent le même
rôle et puis si vous gérez par arbre
c'est plus facile vous vous trompez
c'est plus facile à cicatriser voyez
vous avez fait un choix mais qui est
local
quand vous géré par surface au fait des
choix qui sont beaucoup plus qui vous
engage beaucoup plus fort quoi là par
exemple on a eu des années un peu
compliqué 2018 2019 2020 des années
chaudes si vous en voyez planter des
armes en 2018 bah les jeunes plants à
touget de les replanter enfin 100% tête
obligé de recommencer le boulot donc
vous l'avez fait en 2018 vous leur
faites en 2019 vous leur faites en 2020
voyez vous augmentez les problèmes quoi
si vous avez introduit quelques plans
dans une forêt et à cette fonction micro
climatique cette humidité relative qui
fait que les jeunes ils vont plus
facilement supporter des années qu'on a
des années un peu difficile
ce qu'il ya de ces arrivées ben oui
qui viennent pas faire l'apéro ici
[Musique]
tu les avais pas tout de protéger ouais
d'accord à wilkow ce qu'on en voit là la
ola pour l'instant une pousse tous bien
[Musique]
oh
il est couché là bas c'est une
origination naturel
je suivrai il est pas beau et qui est
couché par là
[Musique]
oh
à
c'est quoi qui t'amène ici toi du coup
moi je suis je représente une petite
association qui s'appelle sans pervis
rence président et donc on a pour
objectif l'acquisition de parcelles
forestières pour mettre un petit peu en
oeuvre des principes expérimente suzanne
déjà depuis depuis un moment il n'y a
que par l'acquisition foncière suite à
une expérience professionnelle passée
qui peut te permettre vraiment d'être
maîtres de la gestion d'un site alors
que quand tu travailles pour par exemple
moi je travaillais pour un parc naturel
régional du coup tu n'étais pas
propriétaire des lieux et même si toi tu
vois des choses qui pourraient être
intéressantes bah forcément le
propriétaire lui l'a pas toujours les
mêmes vues et c'est pas toujours évident
d'arriver à faire passer ses principes
[Musique]
ce que je trouve ça super important
c'est que chaque propriétaire forestier
doit avoir le choix si l'école est
actuellement moi je vois un peu le
manque
d'informations parce que souvent c'est
l'itinéraire classique qui est
promulguée je comprend justement cette
difficulté qui ont certains
propriétaires qui ce qui pense avoir
bien agi parce qu'on leur avait
conseillé de suivre l'itinéraire
classique de planter son hectare ou 50
hectares de d'épicéa et maintenant et se
voit attaqué par des associations ou par
des gens tout à fait normaux en disant
ah vous faites et les cas vous détruisez
la forêt vous fêtez des coupes rases
tandis que et pensait bien faire
et clairement il faut que à nos jours
les propriétaires et s'intéresse vieux
aux différentes possibilités sylvicoles
qu'il y a parce qu'il ya de tout
actuellement en france il ya des
initiatives qui se créent elles il ya
des groupements forestiers écologiques
comme le nôtre qui commencent à émerger
faut qu'il y ait des dialogues et il
faut qu'il ya des collaborations qui
doivent se créer et pas faire que avec
le savoir agricoles parce que souvent en
forêt sachets échoué jusqu'à présent
si la forêt remplit depuis toujours son
rôle de production de bois qu'en est il
de sa fonction écologique promue par les
gouvernements successifs pour lutter
contre la hausse des températures
pour connaître les moyens mis en oeuvre
par les pouvoirs publics j'ai pris
rendez vous avec christine de mazières
conseillère maître à la cour des comptes
et rapporteur de l'enquète sur la
filière forêt bois publié en 2000 rang
[Musique]
c'est un rapport qui a été réalisée à la
demande de l'assemblée nationale pour
regarder l'ensemble de la filière forêt
bois et sous l'angle à la fois
économique et environnemental nous
semble que l'un des enjeux majeurs est
de concilier justement ces deux enjeux
la forêt est à la fois évidemment un
secteur économique extrêmement important
surtout dans les zones rurales sursaut
d'activité et d'emploi mais c'est aussi
le premier puits de carbone donc c'est
un enjeu environnemental tout à fait
majeur selon vous justement quelle
vision à l'état de la forêt quel est le
niveau
d'importance qu'on lui donne est ce que
justement c'est pour produire le bois où
c'est les autres alors jusqu'à présent
si on parle en termes de politiques
publiques la forêt était gérée par
plusieurs ministères
la fois me stable de l'agriculture et de
la forêt
et puis il misa de l'environnement donc
il ya salon vers la transition
écologique est en réalité la politique
forestière n'était une priorité pour
nulle part ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
peut-être que ça évolue maintenant on
espère que notre rapport aura cet impact
là mais on constatait que
il n'y avait pas de politique ferme
forestière pour changer un peu cette
situation critique quelles pourraient
être les pistes de solution on a
notamment proposé au niveau en tout cas
opérationnel que déjà les deux
directeurs généraux
compétents pour la forêt hominis à
l'agriculture et au ministre la
transition écologique se concertent
régulièrement un avantage il faut un
moment quand même avoir une vision à
très long terme pour le coup est donc
une unité d'action
ol
sur le chemin du retour stéphane
souhaite faire découvrir à grégoire les
pratiques sylvicoles auquel ils
s'opposent et qui l'ont amené à la
création de l'association sans perdre y
règne moi j'ai habité là bas il ya
emmené là pendant dix ans d'accord à we
don t vraiment à côté de ce que j'allais
au boulot à pied en vo
c'est bien ce que le siège du parking il
est juste au pied des volcans rouge
toujours dans le parc naturel régional
tu peux voir aussi qu'il ya ce genre de
trucs donc si tu veux tu luttes alterne
entre des paysages de qualité
exceptionnelle et puis des paysages les
fonds c'est bon là en l'occurrence est
une c'est une forêt privée où on
pratique
ce qu'on appelle une si oui je crois
qu'on peut appeler une sylviculture
industrielle donc on a une gestion
forestière qui intègre le retour à zéro
un reset complet et toi c'est quoi ton
point de vue là dessus alors bah moi mon
point de vue c'est je trouve ça
absolument pour rien bien évidemment
c'est moi oui ça me fais moi ça me fait
crever ça me fait crever de tristesse de
voir ça parce que si tu veux pour des
raisons court termisme court termiste de
de retour sur investissement le plus en
plus rapides on a on a appliqué ce qu'on
a fait à l'agriculture dans les années
50 on est en train de l'appliquer à la
forêt depuis maintenant 40 ans et donc
on ne fait pas confiance à la nature on
en a peur et tout ce qui est dû en
dehors de notre contrôle nous fait peur
donc il faut absolument balancer des
grosses machines qui défonce bien les
sols ont fait des belles lignes bien
droites pour qu'on ait le sentiment
d'être chez nous et que tout est sous
contrôle et on va pouvoir se glisser
sous les draps le soir sans faire de
cauchemars
toi tu as eu continuer à avoir envie de
s'impliquer quelle manière aujourd'hui
tu essaie d'agir pour choses évoluent on
veut être en capacité de fournir du bois
sans avoir une action absolument
traumatisante pour l'écosystème
forestier on pense que c'est à peu près
possible mais encore une fois enfin moi
je suis président de l'asso notre but du
jeu c'est juste offrir une alternative
au même titre que tu as des gens qui
font depuis maintenant trente ans en
france mont 40 ans 50 ans la
permaculture qu'aujourd'hui tu as des
thésards de l'inra qui viennent voir
chez eux comment ils font pour avoir dix
fois le rendement au mètre carré de
l'agriculture industrielle sans engrais
sans rien dans que nous très très
modestement on ce modèle là nous plaît
bien si tu veux
nous avons émis à la fin de ce rapport
huit recommandations la première étant
une recommandation sur laquelle le
le citoyen n'attend pas forcément la
cour des comptes à dire qu'on a fait une
recommandation dépensière et nous avons
dit qu'il fallait absolument investir
dans un fonds de repeuplement des forêts
donc de re forestation compte tenu de
nos deux du mauvais état de beaucoup de
forêts à la suite du changement
climatique et donc du dessèchement
beaucoup d'arbres ça veut pas dire que
je regardais des peuplements de
monoculture uniquement de résineux comme
on a pu le faire maintenant il faut
faire des peuplements d'arbres
diversifié qui soit résilience a
justement changement climatique est très
rapide
je milite pour qu'on change le terme de
forêt quand on voit ces politiques de
gestion c'est à dire que ça c'est pas de
la forêt c'est de la sylviculture c'est
la production de bois mais on n'est pas
du tout sur les critères écologiques
d'une forêt donc la forêt ya une
définition précise au niveau écologique
c'est un écosystème qui est pérenne qui
est autogéré parmi nous et qui se
renouvelle absolument tout seul
le rapport aux justement à ces
investissements enfin les subventions
est-ce que ils sont bien distribués ces
soutiens là les ateliers donc il ya une
partie qui va à l'eau nf qui est une
bonne chose il y a quand même
pour près la moitié qui vont en fait
l'incitation à utiliser le bois comme
source d'énergie il ya quasiment pas de
subventions pour les pour les enjeux de
biodiversité
et ça c'est un problème
c'est une constatation
d'accord prêts sont des décisions
politiques donc la cour des comptes elle
elle établit un constat objectif
indépendant mais ne se substitue pas
d'action politique il ya clairement de
l'interventionnisme de la force publique
par le jeu des subventions j'ai rien
contre au motif que j'ai rien contre les
subventions en agriculture mais si
demain l'état choisit par exemple où les
régions ont choisi de réorienter la
manière dont cidal tribus et les
subventions en fonction de l'option
forestière et que si jamais si jamais tu
vas vers de la sylviculture continues tu
vas avoir un peu plus des aides
économiques et bien forcément il va y
avoir un effet d'aubaine etc
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
justement
il faudrait favoriser donc les pratiques
plutôt écologique et mec qui pour elle
est jugée en fait comment on prouve
qu'on est
ça c'est dans les dents dans les
critères de
d'octroi de l'aide qu'on oriente ses
aides vers quelque chose qui soit
réellement une forêt durable votre
question est d'excellente je ne peux pas
y répondre mais vous avez raison il faut
regarder les modalités l'emploi de cet
argent c'est bien d'avoir décidé grosses
sommes mais quelle quels types de forêts
il va favoriser que ça c'est vraiment
très important
mais dans les détails
oui
où
[Musique]
l'hexagone a alloué une enveloppe de 150
millions d'euros à des projets de
reforestation dans le cadre du plan
france relance
le gouvernement ambitionne la création
de 45 mille hectares de forêt qui
permettront de capter 150 mille tonnes
de co2 supplémentaires chaque année
[Musique]
grégoire part à la rencontre de lionel
c'est directeur général de la cfdr la
troisième coopérative forestière de
france bon ben je vous donne le casque
la sécurité c'est un élément très très
important
le métier de fois son neveu culte et
dangereux
[Musique]
c'est non loin des forêts de suzanne en
corrèze qui nous reçoit sur des
parcelles qui ont bénéficié des
subventions de l'état
l'économie de la filière dépend aussi du
soutien public est ce que ces aides vous
encourage à aller plutôt vers un modèle
ouvert un autre de sylviculture alors le
plan de relance il était très bienvenus
pourquoi parce que on a ce problème
important de renouvellement des
peuplements qui sont plus adaptées au
changement climatique et ce plan de
relance cela nous a permis de travailler
sur le renouvellement
des essences donc l'adaptation
climatique a été parfaitement pris en
compte par le plan de relance le
deuxième aspect du plan de relance c'est
la biodiversité
nous mettons n'étaient pas obligés de le
faire nous avons pris des engagements en
matière de reboisement avec des
peuplements qui ne sont pas des
peuplements mono spécifiques souvent
deux essence voire trois essence et sur
nous sur nous au boisement et on a été
retenu avec les critères que nous avons
nous-mêmes indiqué et donc aux vacances
c'est pas l'état qui a fixé ces critères
c'est vous qui l'avez dit nous on va
faire ça et l'état sélectionner les
dossiers notamment le vôtre exactement
exactement
il ya toujours des effets pervers aux
subventions si par exemple vous
je suis vont sillonner plus des
plantations sur les grandes surfaces
vous allez dans le sens de
l'augmentation de l'artificialisation la
forêt je trouve ça dommage
après il faut voir les modalités
pratiques est-ce que j'interviens sur
des surfaces plus grandes
en plein ou est-ce que j'interviens
ponctuellement si j'interviens
ponctuellement bah je vais pouvoir
intervenir sera globalement localement
ce sera sur des surfaces plus petites
mais je vais pouvoir intervenir sur une
plus grande surface
on a une difficulté c'est que souvent
les choix qui sont faits sont faits par
rapport à la facilité de contrôler
l'argent public c'est plus facile de
contrôler une parcelle de 10 hectares
d'une seule fois que d'aller contrôler
sur mille hectares des points d'appui à
droite et à gauche c'est ce qu'ils ont
vraiment été fait vous comprenez le truc
c'est on peut avoir cette facilité du
contrôle qui devient primordial par
rapport à ce que ça peut apporter un
derrière que vous avez aussi des aides
sur les travaux vous avez une aide sur
les travaux
vous inciter à faire des travaux et vous
allez vous allez aider ceux qui ont fait
une gestion plus artificiel donc c'est
ça quand je parle d'effets pervers des
subventions c'est de regarder dans le
mécanisme a quoi sa conduite quoi il ya
de l'emploi ne faut pas oublier c'est
400 mille quatre cent mille emplois donc
là il ya une machine qui travaille tout
seul non alors il ya une seconde fois
c'est important c'est le porteur donc il
vient chercher les bois à parra alors on
va chercher le bois ils vont être triés
bord de route et lui chez deux ans
expliqué ensuite dans la bonne musique
pour être valorisées donc il n'a il
s'agit d'un sous-traitant c'est pas un
porteur de la coopérative il est du coin
du coup vous allez lui poser la question
auxquelles auront à discuter
bonjour
c'est quoi votre boulot ça consiste en
quoi ben moi je vais chercher le bois
dans la poupée germaine au bord des
routes et des pistes celle des bardages
ouais vous fais ça depuis combien de
temps
45 ans vous êtes du coin natif d'ici
vous avez vu pousser du coup j'imagine
c'est paris et le coup ses fruits
comment on le vit quand on va faire du
coup de phrases
on est obligé de la faire et coupes
rases
parce que comme c'est des bras comme ça
qui sont atteints et puis qu'ils sont
vieux en
larmes ou les avait obligés de les
couvrir et il ya des méthodes maintenant
par le civic ou sur irrégulière ou coupe
10% pas plus est-ce que c'est des choses
qui l'intéressent rêve de faire vous en
faites est déjà une question pendante et
c'est différent comme humour comment ça
se passe bien travaillé les éclaircies
maintenant il ya deux mondes éclaircie à
fermer sinon moi je préférais traille
avant avec des trafics dans les coupes
ça a changé la manière de travailler
depuis 20 ans oui
quelqu'un changer un peu tout à bon déjà
on n'a pas beaucoup d'arrêt parce qu'on
a
de moins en moins de l'hiver est bon
maintenant fait des coupes importantes
qui permet de travailler parce que tout
le temps qu
en dit qu'avant on avait des lots
beaucoup plus petits où des éclaircies
où on ne travaillait pas quand il
pleuvait quoi
pour travailler dur quand c'est quand il
fait sec donc après vente et un peu
quand il y quand ils créent de temps
comme aujourd'hui qui peut on y va moins
fort quoi et vous arrivez à vue de votre
métier oui j'avais gagné ma vie c'est
pas mais vous travaillez dur quand vous
travaillez au moins douze ans par l'ong
10 12h dollars et culture
la fin d'un véhicule triste d'ailleurs
et mon fils et ils sont comme moi n'ont
pas de samedi à dimanche vous êtes payés
au volume cesse comment ça se passe moi
je priais voulu plus vous débarder
pouvez payer voilà
pour compte et reconnue dans votre
métier d'affaires connus en ce moment
plutôt dénigrer
à quel niveau on entend beaucoup parler
qu'on est en train de tout couper de
tout de tout saccager de
et on rentre du droit à quoi
aya lequel on arrive là
[Musique]
poussé par le débat citoyen en cours et
face à l'urgence climatique
la question se pose de donner la
priorité à la fonction écologique de la
forêt plutôt qu'à la production de bois
[Musique]
pour nous éclairer sur cette
problématique
j'ai rendez vous avec geneviève vrai
ingénieur général des ponts des eaux et
des forêts et auteurs d'une tribune
intitulée repenser nos usages de la
nature une perspective forestière
son texte a fait grand bruit dans le
monde feutré des forestiers français
elle propose de repenser le droit des
forêts afin de donner la priorité aux
bénéfices apportés par ces écosystèmes
dans la lutte contre la hausse des
températures
[Musique]
on travaille sur des écosystèmes et des
phénomènes qui sont complexes dans une
période de risque aggravé avec le
changement climatique
en fait toute décision qu'on prend il
n'y a pas de bonne solution il qui est
important c'est de
d'éviter les postures et les a priori
entre des forestiers qui sont des
sachants qui en fait une base de
connaissances de ne plus en plus
déstabilisée par le changement
climatique
et puis de l'autre côté par exemple des
échos guerrier qui sont des indes et des
inconditionnels de l'absence de coupes
rases
lui classement en réserve intégrale et
c'est alors ça ça a été un temps les
positions se rapprochent face à la
complexité des dit des choses et la
confrontation si elle est pas trop
violente si elle aboutit sur le dialogue
balle contribuer à trouver des solutions
qui
à construire en fait ensemble des
solutions
[Musique]
où
quand
[Musique]
on
e
sylvie cohen est propriétaire avec sa
fille léa d'une forêt de plus de 1000
hectares situé sur le causse méjean dans
le parc national des cévennes
cette forêt plantée en monoculture dans
les années 50 elle l'a héritée de son
père industriel papetier du nord de la
france
[Musique]
il y a dix ans alan givors expert
forestier a convaincu sylvie de
convertir ces parcelles en futaie
régulière
grégoire est parti à leur rencontre pour
connaître les raisons d'un tel choix et
voir comment cette opération se
concrétise sur le terrain
donc là on arrive sur une zone qui a été
impactée par le gros coup de vent de
2014 et où on a profité de l'occasion
pour ne faire exploiter que les arbres
qui étaient cassées ou tomber et on a
gardé tous qu'ils étaient vivants on a
profité de cet horizon là pour installer
donc il ya des seize independancia de
calabre un peu plus loin et ici des chu
notamment du tilleul merisier merisier
érable âme à lisier termine à lisier
terminal olivier blanc
qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé avec le
groupement forestier de changer votre
mode de gestion ne pas tout coupé et
tout replanter comme on faisait
traditionnellement alors oui c'est vrai
quand on fait une coupe rase tout d'un
coup on se retrouve un peu avec pactole
c'est peut-être excessif et on se
retrouve tout d'un coup avec
voilà le promettent que x tous les
mètres cubes ça fait ça fait de l'argent
mais sa finance pas nécessairement
l'implantation voilà donc ça c'était le
point de départ après ans donc on s'est
rencontré
mais câlins et j'ai découvert la sete
sylviculture qu'on appelle à couvert
continue
j'ai bien discuté avec anna qui m'a un
peu présenté les caractéristiques de
cette sylviculture c'est à dire ne pas
couper d'armes exploiter enfin utiliser
l'existant
et des revenus pour le propriétaire tous
les ans donc ça il parle et je n'avais
pas au porte-monnaie mais enfin c'est
sur moi je suis d'une famille où
l'entreprise massa doit ça doit assurer
sa rentabilité son autofinancement
j'ai une culture familiale et je dois
dire que depuis 20 ans moi j'observe que
les prix qu'on obtient pour dans le
cadre des éclaircies sont des prix qui
sont en progression peut-être mais
mettons dans la fourchette haute des
prix qu'on peut obtenir en laser pour
des bois 2 équivalent donc je pense que
c'était un bon choix un très bon choix
puis nos enfants n'oublieront
[Musique]
ce qui est important c'est de jouer le
plus possible la carte de la
diversification diversification
d'essence de type de peuplement de mode
de conduite en fait c'est la version
scientifique et technique du vieil adage
ne mettant pas tous les oeufs dans le
même panier comment sait pas très bien
comment tout ça va évoluer y compris par
rapport aux changements climatiques y
compris en termes de résistance
de résistance aux incendies de forêt de
résilience on essaie de diversifier au
maximum les approches et on essaie d'en
tirer le maximum d'enseignements
[Musique]
pour moi c'est évident cette vie culture
c'est mieux pour la forêt pour pour des
revenus réguliers le changement de
pratique qui a eu ça avait été décidée
par la mer et j'y adhère complètement et
j'ai été formé aussi
défendre des formes et parle
donc si je peux rajouter le principe est
duplicable ccu une réponse qui a porté
avec des principes de base et des
principes de base donc qui sont les
principes de sylviculture mélangé à
couvert continue qui équiperont
multifonctionnalité de forêt donc ça
c'est entre guillemets les ampleurs et
reproductibles
nous fait ce qui est bien pour notre
environnement pour notre géologie von ah
climat mais voilà ailleurs il faudrait
certainement adapté je pense que la
diversification c'est une bonne chose
mais mais on la fait pas partout de la
même manière
non
vous avez exercé
cette conversion en sylviculture
irrégulière a couvert continue et tout
autant motivés par l'aspect financier
que par la nécessité de préparer sa
forêt au climat de demain
[Musique]
le meilleur des deux mondes en somme
l'équilibré entre écologie économie et
résilience
[Musique]
à la vue des bouleversements climatiques
présents et futurs la question se pose
aujourd'hui de repenser la gestion
forestière en donnant la priorité aux
fonctions écologiques plutôt qu'à la
production de bois
geneviève vrai à étudier cette question
tout au long de sa carrière
clairement le droit de l'environnement
est en train de se structurer avec des
conventions avec les grands convention
cadre qui ont très longtemps été
considéré d'ailleurs par les forestiers
et le monde agricole comme du droit mou
un truc des engagements généraux et on
voit bien que ça se durcit et à juste
titre et que c'est en train la
convention sur les changements
climatiques on peut recruter pour
regretter que les coop
naboo n'est pas les conséquences qu'on
pourrait souhaiter et ne soit pas suivi
de l'action qu'on ne pourrait souhaiter
mais on voit quand même clairement se
construit petit à petit du droit dur qui
est en train d'orienter les choses et
effectivement il ya ya ya ya des termes
comme le le le bien commun ou contrat
social qui sont en train de cristalliser
les oppositions et qui sont qui sont qui
sont qui sont pour certains le
propriétaire notamment propriétaires
forestiers privés une espèce de spectre
de crypto collectivisme rampant qui
vient mettre en cause le droit de
propriété
alors je sais pas si la solution c'est
bien commun je sais pas si la solution
c'est donner une personnalité juridique
à la nature ça se fait dans certains cas
mais c'est quelque chose qui est en
train de bouger en même temps d'ailleurs
que la société s'investit et investit le
sujet forestiers comme l'a investi celui
du bien-être animal
j'allais dire que c'est un débat qui en
soi est intéressant et c'est sans doute
l'avenir du droit forestier qui se joue
en partie là alors il se jouera avec les
forestiers se sont emparés qu'il y
participe il se jouera je dirais à côté
d'eux sans eux et donc ils vont
considérer que ça se jouera entre eux si
la v6 pas
pour assurer notre avenir il faudrait
tout changer notre approche de la forêt
pour ne plus la voir uniquement comme un
stock de bois mais comme un écosystème
complexe dont les bénéfices pour la
société dépasse largement les profits
obtenus par la production de matière
difficile de savoir de quoi demain sera
fait les certitudes des uns vont elles
prendre le pas sur les doutes des autres
le débat est en cours sur cette question
de l'avenir de la forêt de son
importance sur les écosystèmes et du
droit qu'elle doit revêtir mais je me
demande si aujourd'hui nous avons encore
le temps d'avoir le droit à l'erreur
dans tous les cas j'espère que nous
ferons le bon choix les bons choix
[Musique]
oh